How do you understand the number 462?
I mean we know it's 462.
But how do we look at it in terms of its digits?
In every number each digit you see has a place value.
And that depends entirely on where the digit is placed or positioned.
Here, the digit two is in the ones place.
While six is in the tens place and four in the hundreds place.
With the help of place value, let's try to break this number down.
As four lies in the hundreds place, we can write four times 100.
As six is in the tens place,
we add six times ten to this.
And as two is in the ones place we add two times one.
That's how we understand the number 462.
400+ 60+2
But what if we have a decimal point in the number?
Say a number like 462.351.
How do we understand this number?
It's simple!
The digits that appear before the decimal point,
work just like this one.
It will be four times 100, plus six times ten, plus two times one.
But what is the place value of the digits after the decimal point?
The first digit after the decimal point in this case is three.
Is it in the tens place?
Not tens, its tenths place.
So it's value would be three times 1 by 10
or three tenths we can say.
The second digit to the right of the decimal point
which is five is in the hundredths place.
It means that its value will be five times 1 by 100.
The third digit to the right of the decimal point,
which is one, is said to be in the thousandths place.
So we add one multiplied by one by one thousand.
If you add these six values,
you will get four hundred sixty-two point three five one.
Decimals are just another way of representing fractions.
This number can also be written as
four hundred and sixty two thousand three hundred and fifty one
by one thousand.
As they are another way of representing fractions,
they are called decimal fractions.
Notice that as we move towards the right
the place value reduces to one tenth of the previous place value.
100 by 10 is 10, 10 by 10 is 1 and so on...
Here,
462 is called the integral part of the number.
And 351 is called the decimal part.
There are many things we need to understand about decimal fractions.
Their types, ways to compare them,
operations on them and many more concepts.
We will understand these in the next few videos.